[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales
voici les titres de l'actualité se faire
vacciner tard le soir après le couvre
feu c'est désormais possible pour
accélérer la vaccination des centres
ouvrent désormais jusqu'à 23 heures
reportage de tv 78 à suivre dès le début
de ce journal dans un instant nos modes
de consommation ont évolué depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire en gironde
vous verrez la rédaction de tv7 nous
fera découvrir le premier drive fermiers
de france créée il ya neuf ans son
succès n'est plus à démontrer et actions
l'espace aussi dans ce grand journal des
territoires une entreprise d'avignon a
été sélectionné pour envoyer des graines
qui serviront à thomas pesquet à bord de
l' agence spatiale internationale sujet
nos partenaires de la provence enfin sur
terre cette fois-ci des étudiants ont la
chance unique depuis plusieurs semaines
de restaurer une reproduction de la
fameuse batmobile d'une formation aux
métiers de l'automobile extraordinaire
que nous expliquera la rédaction devient
95 une vaccination rendu possible
maintenant jusqu'à 23h et dans les
yvelines s'est tous les vendredis soir
que le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin administre des vaccins
bien au delà des horaires autorisés du
couvre feu
une heure tardive pour faciliter l'accès
au vaccin pour les personnes en activité
et qui permet bien sûr d'accélérer le
rythme de la vaccination localement à
reportage de mélanie poquet pour la
chaîne des yvelines télé 78 près 2 506
viennois vacciner la nocturne au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines a
eu du succès une ouverture jusqu'à
minuit ce vendredi 30 avril pour
recevoir les patients en activité j'ai
très très bien très bien parce que moins
ça permet de venir en dehors des heures
de boulot
pour les personnes qui travaillent qui
travaillent tard jusqu'à 18 19 heures
c'est une très bonne idée effectivement
23 ça permet de 500 dehors des heures de
bureau
petite bonne opportunité pour ceux qui
travaillent entre autres et puis voilà
ça ouvre plus de créneaux quoi pour en
profiter l'agglomération note que 50%
des patients viennent de l'extérieur de
saint quentin en yvelines
pour cette première soirée ce sont des
doses pfizer qui ont été administrés 500
primovaccination les gens qui
travaillent et bien ils ont ils
travaillent la journée et donc il faut
qu'ils viennent le soir donc voilà voilà
la raison et deuxièmement ça nous permet
à nous de nous préparer puisque bien
entendu on sent bien que il ya plus de
gens de 50 ans que des gens de 60 donc
bien sûr ça va en quantité il faut se
préparer à augmenter bien sûr le nombre
de vaccinations
après cette première soirée test le
vélodrome sera en nocturne tous les
vendredis soirs depuis le 1er mai la
vaccination est ouverte aux français de
plus de 18 ans souffrant d'une ou de
plusieurs co morbidités la date est
cochée sur le calendrier de beaucoup de
français le 19 mai les salles de cinéma
pourront reprendre leurs activités
enfin avec un protocole sanitaire
exigeant gestes-barrières et ventilation
des salles entre deux projections le
groupe grand écran comme beaucoup de
gestionnaires est actuellement en pleine
préparation
son siège est à limoges sur place alain
dru aux 2,7 à limoges ci rendu au regard
des dix complexe 83 salle 130 personnes
plus de deux millions de spectateurs
dans une année ordinaire
c'est la carte d'identité du groupe
grand écran présent dans le sud-ouest
dont le siège est à limoges où comme
dans tous les autres sites du groupe se
prépare la reprise du 19 mai il fallait
faire tourner les serveurs et les
projecteurs pour régénérer les cadets
aime parce que sinon ils perdent leur
connexion partie leur prénom qu'il faut
aussi faire chauffer la machine et tous
les ventilations à vérifier
et comme ça tourne en permanence toutes
les poussières il faut nettoyer et
vérifier le liquide agissements voilà
pour l'infrastructure
on annonce un embouteillage avec 400
films prêt à déferler sur les écrans il
a déjà une première chose tous les
signes qui étaient en cours
d'exploitation par la plupart des kings
étaient en cours d'exploitation qui ne
sont pas sorties ratées ou en idiots des
romans de la fermeture vont ressortir et
ensuite on va avoir des nouveautés qui
vont apparaître sa montée crescendo
jusqu'à l'été on commençait à voir avant
les grosses machines américaines à
partir du 14 juillet priori y aura
beaucoup de films mais malheureusement
pas encore beaucoup de séances parce
qu'on va être contraint certains
limite de couvre-feu ou deux espaces
entre les séances pour aérer et ainsi de
suite
mais on va faire deux trois séances par
jour sont les jours avec un maximum de
fumer un fichu sollicité pendant la
crise sanitaire les internes en médecine
vivent et se forment depuis plus d'un an
au rythme du coc vide dans les vosges
chaque semestre plusieurs dizaines de
ces internes intègre les différents
services des hôpitaux locaux à saint dié
la nouvelle promotion profitera d'un
internat entièrement rénové anthony sap
et anne didier pour vient vosges une
nouvelle promotion interne une nouvelle
génération de médecins en novembre puis
en mai ils sont plusieurs dizaines à
intégrer les différents services des
hôpitaux vosgien 11 ce lundi matin
ici à saint dié eux profiteront d'un
internat entièrement rénové il était
également 21 remiremont et 50 dans le
nouvel hôpital d'epinal la première
promotion intégrée cet établissement
flambant neufs même si selon son
directeur
ce n'est pas un critère déterminant dans
le choix des stagiaires
c'est surtout l'encadrement médical et
l'encadrement des seniors qui fait la
qualité d'un stage donc les internes ils
recherchent avant tout
d'intégrer une équipe et surtout d'avoir
une vie
un soutien de la part pédagogique de la
part des chefs de service et des
médecins à l'hôpital
ils viennent donc d'un peu partout en
france et on choisit les vosges pour
parfaire leur formation certains d'entre
eux bénéficient d'ailleurs déjà d'une
solide expérience sollicité ces derniers
mois ou volontaires pour faire face à la
pandémie
de fait la première vague de qu'ovide a
changé on avait commencé bas du cou en
mars à peu près pendant le confinement
c'était sur la base du volontariat mais
j'ai continué parce qu'il y avait des
nouvelles vagues et puis on a ouvert
d'autres secteurs il ya un secteur qui
avait fermé points et du candidat passe
donc forcément on en a fait il ya des
moments vraiment c'était compliqué en
plus on va dire qu'on s'attache aux gens
c'est des gens qui sont soit en crise
une quinzaine de jours après ça dépend
du type de patients mais c'est sûr que
ça passe a pas été évident depuis un an
encore
la bonne nouvelle c'est que la situation
semble doucement s'améliorer un peu
partout en france et les vosges ne font
pas exception
la tendance est à la baisse pour les
chiffres de la contamination comme pour
le nombre de patients en service de
soins critiques
la situation s'améliore un que ce soit
sur épinal comme sur remiremont avec un
peu moins de pression au niveau des
urgences est un peu moins de pression
dans les services de médecine en en pôle
éco vide
ces tendances plutôt à la baisse on en
est extrêmement satisfait au monde a
repris une activité activités
opératoires aujourd'hui 1 voilà donc on
est plutôt dans le bon sens ce nouveau
semestre sera t'il un peu plus calme
pour ces internes en médecine difficile
à dire la seule certitude c'est qu'en
cas de nouvelle vague de l'épidémie
beaucoup d'entre eux se retrouveront à
nouveau en première ligne
et si les abeilles sauver nos
associations dans la loire un apiculteur
est devenu partenaire d'un club de foot
le fc val d aix et l'achat du miel à bas
prix a permis au club de réaliser
quelques bénéfices à la revente
une manne financière bienvenue puisque
toutes les compétitions et événements
sportifs amateurs sont suspendus à cause
bien sûr de la pandémie
l'argent collecté grâce à ce partenariat
solidaire agricole et locales financera
le réaménagement de l'une des pelous du
club des images d'adrien bletterie de la
rédaction de tl7 et c'est l'un des
effets positifs de la crise sanitaire et
déconfinement le succès des circuits
courts ne se dément plus environ 2 vous
allez le voir la chambre d'agriculture a
créés dès 2012 le premier drive fermiers
de france une offre qui satisfait autant
les consommateurs que les producteurs et
dominique parmentier pour la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest tv7 ci rendu clair
arino est devenue productrice asperges
sur l'exploitation familiale de saint
christoly de blaye en 2017
sur ses 5 hectares elle récolte chaque
jour pendant la saison près de 200 kg
d'aspergés toutes catégories qu'elle
vendait jusqu'ici exclusivement sur les
marchés et puis il ya un an il y a eu la
crise le confinement et la fermeture des
marchés
moi j'ai pas supporté de me dire je vais
jeter dans la marchandise alors que
finalement autour de nous il ya des gens
qui ont besoin de manger etc ont besoin
d'avoir des légumes frais et quand mais
on se retrouve simple rien pour vendre
il faut trouver une autre solution
et cette année j'ai découvert le drive
fermiers
aujourd'hui la vente sur les marchés a
repris mme un tiers de sa production
alimente le dry fermiers ce qui lui
permet de ne pas mettre tous ses oeufs
dans le même panier et surtout de vendre
localement nous nos marchés était tout
seul en
ordonne ue en charente donc c'est une
porte ouverte sur les la clientèle
bordelaise et c'est important
aujourd'hui ce sont une cinquantaine de
producteurs ou coopératives
essentiellement de gironde qui propose
plus de 700 produits conventionnels ou
bio dans les cinq points de retrait dans
cadre dans la métropole bordelaise comme
ici à eysines et les commandes ont
explosé avec la crise sanitaire
et depuis le premier confinement il
entend donc que voudra est permis ça
fait depuis la pandémie oui pour avoir
des choses en drive et avoir reçu du
produits locaux et de saison
un succès qui ne se dément pas donc à
tel point qu'un point de retrait
supplémentaire notamment dans le
centre-ville de bordeaux serait le
bienvenu à bon entendeur
restons dans le sud pour vous parler de
cette autre façon de s'alimenter
localement une péniche chargée de
produits agroalimentaires à quitter
lundi le port de damazan dans le
lot-et-garonne
elle transporte des marchandises locales
issues de l'agriculture biologique
destination bordeaux le long du canal
la garonne c'est le collectif garonne
fertile composé de producteurs de
consommateurs et de distributeurs qui a
organisé ce voyage pilote un mode de
transport plus lent certes mais aussi
plus doux et plus écologiques images et
réactions de manon aussi pour nos
confrères de la dépêche du midi sur
place mais la première chose qu'on
voulait démontrer c'était c'était
c'était possible de le faire déjà dans
les conditions actuelles
et si on s'associe avec d'autres si
d'autres personnes ont envie de
s'engager sur ces questions là on peut
arriver à quelque chose n'a rien inventé
et aujourd'hui est d'abord l'activité
par le passé y était déjà
simplement il sait comment on pouvait la
remettre réaction alors que l'astronaute
français thomas pesquet est désormais
bien installé au coeur de la station
spatiale internationale vous l'avez
beaucoup vu partout et bien sur terre on
prépare déjà la suite de la mission
alpha à avignon la société spg qui
produit plus de 15 millions de graines
florales et potagères parents a été
sélectionné pour participer à l'un des
projets de la station en effet les
oeillets d'inde conditionnait avignon
vont être envoyés au mois d'août dans
l'espace pour rejoindre thomas pesquet
l'astronaute aura alors la
responsabilité de les arroser et
d'observer la germination des graines
une mission unique à laquelle
l'entreprise participe avec beaucoup de
fierté
maxime payons pour nos partenaires de la
provence sur place
c'est ce qui est incroyable c'est que
c'est très récent et que pour le coup on
n'a pas du tout été proactif dans cette
démarche là on a reçu une formation aux
alentours du 1er avril pour tout vous
dire
au début on a presque cru à un poisson
d'avril le patron de cette entreprise a
encore du mal à y croire
ici à avignon on conditionne plus de 15
millions de sachets semences potagères
et florales
mais l'un d'entre eux a attiré
l'attention des étudiants du projet
éclosion en lien direct avec la mission
alpha saisonniers d'inde vont partir
rejoindre thomas pesquet dans l'espace
le 1er août prochain le rôle de toi
parce qu'il sera tous les jours
devenir hydrater le substrat pour
apporter bien sur l'eau qui est
essentiel au développement de la plante
et aux différents stades de
développement 2,7 et d'inde
il pourra non seulement l'observer mais
également prendre dans le socle de la
capsule des petits cartons avec des
odeurs de fleurs et sur lesquels ses
membres de la famille de sa famille sont
venus inscrire des petits mots une
expérience et une mission inédite pour
thomas pesquet une fierté aussi pour
l'entreprise avionnaise c'est un immense
honneur qui nous est fait déjà parce que
nos graines ont été sélectionnés sur
leur pouvoir germinatif tirent sur leur
qualité a germé de manière très efficace
au delà de est-ce que la graine va
germer ou non ça sera surtout comment
une petite fleur avec sa beauté son
odeur va amener quelque chose qui est
essentielle à temps parce que c'est à
dire un lien avec la nature et en
attendant dans les jardineries le
phénomène pesqué prend de l'ampleur
les jardiniers amateurs veulent eux
aussi planter leurs graines de dinde de
quoi se mesurer à thomas pesquet et
l'économie dans nos régions maintenant
direction cette semaine la bretagne avec
vous ou michele picot aujourd'hui vous
nous inviter à découvrir la monnerie
polique qui a développé notamment des
solutions extrêmement innovante et
peut-être même unique au monde dans sa
production de farine michel bonjour sert
il
bonjour à toutes et à tous direction la
bretagne aujourd'hui à saint gérand
précisément dans le morbihan
pour découvrir une meunerie extrêmement
innovante à tel point qu'elle est
peut-être unique au monde sa principale
innovation qui a fait l'objet de cinq
brevets internationaux s'appelle auxi
green
il s'agit d'un système de traitement
innovant d'ozonation des grains de blé
ce système permet de purifier les grains
de blé éliminer les produits chimiques
et tout en laissant en fait aucune trace
ses grains sont ensuite destinés à la
production de farine pour l'alimentation
humaine
cette farine haut de gamme s'appelle
calysta elle favorise la panification
sans additif ni conservateur et avec une
teneur en fibres plus élevé mais ce
traitement permet aussi de nettoyer le
son de blé c'est à dire l'enveloppent
qui protège le gras le son de blé est
utilisé pour nous et ensuite des
insectes d'élevage et comme vous le
savez bien souvent eh bien ces insectes
sont transformés en farine nourrissent
les poissons d'élevage et ses poissons
ne finisse dans nos assiettes
autant bien au real et poissons enfin
vous me direz pour avoir de bons grande
bleue cela passe aussi par une bonne
culture et bien polique meunerie et
quelques producteurs bretons ont lancé
la filière merci les algues en fait des
algues nourrissent les plants de blé
pour éviter d'utiliser des insecticides
ou encore des fongicides de synthèse ses
innovations font de polygones riz une
agritech de premier plan qui surf sur
des manches en plein boom pour l'homme
manger sans avec des produits 100 mais
aussi sur un marché de l'alimentation
des insectes d'élevage également en
plein essor visionnaire et innovante
polique meunerie et certainement unique
au monde est allé bretonne et puis
michel picaud bon anniversaire vous
fêter les deux ans de business club
votre émission alors vraiment bon
anniversaire à vous innovante elle aussi
l'expérimentation irie alto va bientôt
voir le jour près de narbonne
ce projet unique en france permet
d'utiliser les eaux usées traitées en
station d'épuration pour irriguer les
vignobles situés sur les coteaux de
gruissan une solution prometteuse pour
faire face à la répétition des
sécheresses
écoutez ses explications d'alisa marty
pour vient occitanie jean-michel et
viticulteurs depuis 30 ans ici à
gruissan dans l'aude
au fil des années cet enfant du pays a
vu naître une problématique l'irrigation
de là
ligne car sur ces coteaux la sécheresse
est constante et les vignerons n'ont pas
accès à l'eau l'irrigation c'est quelque
chose d'obligatoire maintenance et
irriguer la vigne d'abord pour la
maintenir en vie il ne faut pas que la
vie n'y rentre un stress hydrique impôts
pour qu'elle puisse vivre correctement
les données bien évidemment matière à
faire de mauvais son vignoble va
désormais être irriguées en eaux usées g
grâce au projet irie alto lancé par le
grand narbonne et c'est à quelques
mètres de là à l'institut national de
recherche pour l'agriculture que des
expérimentations sont réalisés depuis
quel impact sur le sol sur la vigne le
raisin jusqu'au 20 ans sorti nous avons
démontré qu' il n'y avait pas d'effet de
la qualité d'eau et que la qualité c
était suffisante pour pouvoir irriguer
la vigne
la qualité c'est en la qualité d'eau la
moins coûteuse a généré en sortie de
station d'épuration
c'est donc la station d'épuration de
gruissan qui va traiter les eaux usées
de la station balnéaire qui accueille
une forte activité touristique au moment
où la vigne a le plus besoin d'eau on va
récupérer l'eau usée en sortie de
station qui normalement retourne à la
mer et nous on va mettre en place un
traitement en fait spécifique qui va
permettre en fait de respecter des
normes de qualité très poussées afin de
rendre totalement en innocuité l'eau qui
sera alimenté derrière au niveau des
parcelles des différentes villes il ya
des études qui ont été défaites sur
toutes les stations d'épuration du dur
et narbonne et pour progressivement en
fonction des demandes en fonction des
besoins et en fonction des finances
bague portée d'autres projets cette
expérimentation va d'abord se faire sur
80 hectares de vignobles au total
quarante mille mètres cubes d'eau par an
vont irriguer ses vignes et puis un coup
de projecteur dans ce grand journal de
territoire sur les éditions locales du
magazine le point tout d'abord l'édition
nice cette semaine le dossier sur l'eco
vallée dans la plaine du var lancé en
2008 par christian estrosi les plus
grandes opérations de l'hexagone qui
s'étend sur plus de 2
mille hectares avec l'immeuble à nice et
ses bureaux terrasse et modulable puis
l'ex directeur monde d'apple qui veut
faire des alpes maritimes une terre
d'intelligence artificielle
c'est dans le magazine le point cette
semaine dans l'édition spéciale
nice et puis l'édition spéciale toulouse
du point qu'il faut signaler également
cette semaine
dossier sur l'avenir aéronautique après
la crise sanitaire des drones ambulance
aussi dans le ciel toulousain une
expérimentation de la livraison
aériennes médicales en 2022
et puis star wars au cnes emmanuel
macron le président de la république
assiste à une simulation de guerre
spatiale
tout cela dans l'édition spéciale
toulouse du point cette semaine près du
mans nouveau coup dur pour un éleveur du
nord de la sarthe après une liquidation
judiciaire de son activité
il voit désormais son ancienne
exploitation démoli l'activité de
patrick pilon avait dû cesser à la fin
de l'année 2019 alors que ces lapins
étaient victimes d'une surmortalité
inexpliquée la cause invoquée bien
c'était les ondes électromagnétiques dû
à la proximité d'une antenne relais
aujourd'hui la démolition survient sans
qu'aucune expertise net eu lieu à
reportage d'anthony picton pour vyas
hellemmes terry sur place quelques amas
de tôle froissée mais surtout beaucoup
d'amertume dans les décombres de son
ancienne exploitation patrick
s'interrogent personne ne l'a prévenu
d'un point de vue légal j'ai rien à
redire
d'un point de vue humain je ne comprends
pas au prix japonais un minimum un petit
appel pour dire voilà on n'est pas
arrivé jour-là en trois jours quatre
mille mètres carrés d'installations
agricoles sont démolis direction le
recyclage depuis la liquidation
judiciaire le bâtiment ne lui appartient
plus pourtant certaines pièces auraient
pu être revendue
les images sont choquantes je suis pas
tellement surpris ils sont hyper
choquant notamment au niveau des stylos
il pouvait être récupérés et valorisés
il faut dix minutes pour démontrer un
silo à ces quatre boulons donc je ne
comprends pas la motivation de détruire
pour détruire à par apam affectés
psychologiquement
à l'origine de toutes ces souffrances la
surmortalité des lapins de son élevage
qui a conduit à la fin de son activité
aujourd'hui c'est l'antenne relais à
proximité qui est pointé du doigt un
combat auquel veut se joindre le maire
venu apporter son soutien je me pose des
questions et surtout jeu je me demande
pourquoi on a détruit aussi vite alors
qu'on avait ici un outil qui nous
permettait de mesurer un tas de choses
de mener des investigations
scientifiques pour comprendre ce qui se
passe il y assure sans doute ici une
situation particulière liée à une haute
tension avec des antennes relais à côté
ce qu'il faut c'est comprendre moi la
seule chose que je veux c'est comprendre
comprendre comprendre pour ne pas
reproduire une expertise électrique
devait avoir lieu dans les prochains
jours l'éleveur reste déterminée à
poursuivre son action afin de faire
reconnaître les effets des ondes
électromagnétiques
une page d'histoire à présent dans ce
grand jt des territoires cette semaine
la france commémorait le bicentenaire de
la mort de napoléon dans les hauts de
france la chaîne wéo la chaîne de la
voix du nord a pu rencontrer philippe
melaine un passionné des pièces
insolites datant du premier et du second
empire depuis plus de 40 ans
collectionneur déniche les meilleures
pièces de l'époque
parmi elles un portrait de napoléon 1er
rencontre avec jérôme houbron pour jouer
ou la chaîne de la voix du nord tant qu
un capuchon de deux bouteilles de vin
le petit soldat en plomb un canot va
signer le bus de l'empereur et pourquoi
pas je ne fume plus mais allumé une
cigarette avec ce briquet des babioles
des gadgets parfois des trésors philippe
meylan n'accumule d'état chez lui à plat
chez million depuis plus de 40 ans parmi
les centaines d'objets rassemblés dans
ce qu'il appelle son musée on y retrouve
sa pièce maîtresse un portrait de
napoléon 1er par horace vernet mon oncle
le dernier et grand militaire de famille
me l'a léguée avec bien sûr interdiction
de le vendre
ça se garde de génération en génération
c'est un personnage c'est un personnage
que j'ai après entouré aussi de
beaucoup de pièces de musée c'était le
fil conducteur qui m'a permis de
démarrer une modeste collection en plus
d'avoir une valeur sentimentale pour
philippe lavera bien failli disparaître
1939 1945 le tableau était caché tout
simplement dans un sac en toile de jute
puisque la famille étant des meuniers
s'il était resté au dessus de la
cheminée
le premier officier allemand qui passe
et aurait certainement emmené le tableau
buste documents officiels chapeau philip
combien tu as à faire sa collection
autant de trésors qu'il transmettra à
son tour la restauration d'une voiture
pas comme les autres pour terminer ce
grand jt des territoires vous l'avez vu
sur les images tout à l'heure dans les
titres depuis le mois de février les
élèves du gard à l'école nationale des
métiers de l'automobile basée à
argenteuil restaure une réplique de la
batmobile cette voiture unique en son
genre est issu du film batman réalisé
par tim burton en 1989 elle sera ensuite
exposé évidemment dans un musée de
l'essonne consacré aux véhicules issus
de la télévision et du cinéma
mais en attendant michael joly pour la
rédaction de vie à 95 a pu monter dedans
pour nous cet après midi là dans cet
atelier du gard ac école nationale des
professions de l'automobile
les élèves de bac pro travail sur la
carrosserie d'un véhicule hors du commun
une réplique de la batmobile la voiture
du super héros batman pilotes dont le
film du réalisateur tim burton sorti en
1989 le garac par son community manager
la chance de rencontrer un propriétaire
d'une map mobile
il nous a proposé de travailler sur ce
fond musical extraordinaire mythique et
si une opération inédite pour le gard ac
et ça a donné la possibilité à des
jeunes de travailler sur un véhicule
deux films ce qui n'est pas courant une
peinture noire mate identique aux films
doivent également être réalisées par les
élèves de ces apps est un exercice
formateur en raison des matériaux
composites présents sur ce véhicule de
plus de 6 mètres de long et de 2 mètres
de large
ici on voit bien qu'on est sur la fibre
de verre donc on va aller dans le sens
où côté là on est assez loin
on va continuer par contre c'est sur
cette zone à ce sont des matériaux qui
sont amenées à se développer
vu l'engouement des véhicules
électriques pour gagner du poids il ya
également la possibilité de faire des
modèles des véhicules avec différentes
formes là s'est rapidement avec un coup
c'est avec un coût moindre par rapport à
de l'acier on est vraiment sur une phase
d'apprentissage projet qui va être
intéressant pour les prochaines années
un projet également réjouissant pour les
élèves et un véhicule qu'on voit jamais
qui est très rare en plus et vient que
la matière avec laquelle est faite la
voiture c'est spécial donc c'est des
techniques différentes pour faire
beaucoup plus attention que s'ils ont
travaillé sur du plastique vous attend
la restauration de la batmobile doit
être achevé en juin 2021
elle sera ensuite exposée dans un musée
de l'essonne consacré aux véhicules
issus du petit et du grand écran
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes tnt locale
et régionale et à très vite pour une
prochaine édition havre à tous
[Musique]